all right and welcome to hannity tonight
the biden administration is in a free
fall and i mean literally as it turns
out even long weekends at the beach are
a struggle for poor joey
on saturday as you probably know by now
the president fell yet again this time
he was unable to maintain his balance
after leisurely taking a bike ride in
delaware with the first lady
thankfully with some help some nice
people around him he was able to get
back on his feet and now he's okay this
comes amid growing concerns from the
democrats in the left and even the new
york times about the president's mental
and physical fitness even fake news cnn
now even some democrats are questioning
biden's abilities and casting doubt on a
second term which he says he's going to
run for
of course the white house is well aware
of these concerns and this weekend in
order to reassure you the american
people they had the president perform a
variety of frankly
embarrassing political physical acts
in other words they put on a show
ultimately did more harm than good for
example on friday joe did his very best
sprinting all the way out to marine one
good job joe then on saturday he suited
up like a competitive cyclist fell off
his bicycle when it came to a stop and
on sunday he pretended to jump rope in
front of the cameras and was kind of sad
deeply concerning there is jumping rope
good job joe 79 year old president uh
has been pretty much unable to stay
upright now remember you know this
particular incident remember the white
house they blame the first major fall or
three falls was a very windy day i don't
know what's worse the fact that he fell
three times or they're lying to us and
said it was a windy day that's probably
why he fell if he's that weak that the
wind is blowing him over it's not
exactly a hurricane over there uh anyway
but as of this hour we have not heard if
they're claiming the winds blew joe over
on his bicycle like they suggested for
the reason that he tripped three times
going up the stairs at air force one
take a look
so the president take a fall on the
stairs is he doing okay so as you know
it's pretty windy outside it's very
windy i almost felt coming up the steps
myself he is doing 100
fine
it's windy outside i go out with the
president i could barely keep up the new
white house press secretary says okay
this time they're changing their tune up
a little bit the white house is blaming
the bike naturally the media mob is
totally unconcerned and more than happy
to look the other way and they're barely
reporting on biden's fall at all but
remember two years ago when then
president donald trump carefully
walked down a wet ramp that didn't have
any guardrails at all
in slick dress shoes you know kind of
dangerous have you ever tried it not
good anyway he went down slowly the
media mob went ballistic they all but
accused him of having a
neurological disorder of some kind take
a look
the president himself uh as having
momentary uh stumbles uh momentary
lapses and you know looks restraining
for a word or whatever uh it might be
you know the president you know spending
time in his weekend getaway there in
delaware he likes to get out sometimes
interact with people but perhaps this
was not the interaction that he was
planning or hoping for today
he took a little bit of a tumble while
biking but how is he doing really
so maybe he just
has a hard time going down a gently
sloping ramp but um do you see something
possibly neurological that could be
throwing off his balance president biden
fell off his bike in front of a crowd
and the press there in rehoboth beach
delaware the president said that the tow
cages on his bike got caught and that
caused him to fall sideways president
biden says he's a-okay and there are no
visible scrapes or bruises from the
spill biden is jabbing back pointing to
mr trump's slow descent down a ramp at a
west point commencement earlier this
year look at how he steps and look how i
stepped
watch how i run up gramps and he
stumbles down ramps okay come on
all right so the media mob joe biden and
his entire administration are all in
denial but not just about joe's mental
and physical stamina they're also in
denial about the crisis on the southern
border
they are in denial about violent crime
in american cities they are in denial
about inflation at a 41-year high denial
about of course oh the highest gas
prices we've ever experienced five six
bucks a gallon and in denial about the
looming recession as a result of his
economic and energy policies take a look
even more likely than ever not the
majority of them aren't saying that come
on don't make things up okay
now you're sounding like a republican
politician i'm joking that was a joke
but all kids aside no i don't think it
is
and according to bloomberg's economic
models and the economist and former
obama economic adviser larry summers
well this country is all but certain to
fall into a recession by 2024 but again
joe and the entire administration they
are in denial we see the same thing with
gas prices take a look
the idea we're going to be able to
you know click a switch
bring down the cost of gasoline
is not likely in their term the
president has said and made very clear
that there's not much left that he can
do unfortunately that is the brutal
reality the reality is uh that there
isn't very much more to be done with
respect to energy the
administration has done everything that
they can to bring down energy costs
this is where i get really angry we've
done everything we can there's not much
else we can do they artificially reduce
the world's supply you don't need to go
to harvard business school or mit or an
ivy league school to figure out supply
and demand they crisscross and they
dictate the price and that guy in your
screen artificially reduced the world's
supply of oil and gas and the price has
gone up dramatically and now he's about
to kiss the ass of the crown prince
of that nation called saudi arabia the
pariah nation as he call it calls it the
guy that
he accused of killing journalist jamal
khashoggi is about to suck up to him
like to suck it up to venezuela like
they're sucking up to iran because of
this climate alarmist religious cult
well none of this is going to happen all
this was preventable and it's all
fixable you could simply restart the
keystone xl pipeline we'll get 900 000
barrels of canadian oil a day start
there they could lift the drilling ban
in anwar we have pretty much unlimited
supplies there and other federal lands
license permits to the oil companies
they can lift restrictions on fracking
and refineries but instead of taking
those productive steps to ramp up
domestic production of oil and gas they
act like well they throw up their hands
we've done everything we can
small town mayor turned transportation
secretary in over his head pete but a
judge treasury secretary janet yellen
out to lunch are talking about some
vague switch to renewables once we are
energy uh independent with renewables uh
we'll be able to uh get lower prices on
energy
what renewables exactly explaining what
technology are they talking about
where are they when will they come
online and what is the plan here and can
anyone in the administration answer any
of these questions and if these phantom
renewables are so great why is biden
headed to saudi arabia the pariah nation
as he calls it to kiss the ass of the
crown prince who accused he accused the
murder what to beg him to pump more oil
why not just go to midland texas why not
go to north dakota why not for natural
gas go to ohio and pennsylvania and
create high-paying career jobs and not
have to put the lifeblood of our economy
in the hands of people many of whom do
not like us i don't like that guy i
don't trust that guy and nor should we
saudi arabia opec nations venezuela iran
they all pretty much hate us now sadly
we're now being led by complete total
fools and morons and our transportation
secretary former mayor of south bend
indiana doesn't know what he's doing the
energy secretary is a self-proclaimed
environmentalist who hates the oil and
gas industry a year ago the treasury
secretary told the world inflation was
transitory and now this country is
barreling into another painful summer
spiking prices record high inflation
record high gas prices and get ready for
the rolling brownouts that are on the
way along with a president who is unable
and unwilling to work hard or answer
questions or sit down for interviews or
do pretty much anything of value take a
look
mr president
i will not talk to you on my vacation
yes i'm gonna be talking to
i i'll not talk to you i'm on vacation
falling off my bicycle to be honest our
country would probably be a lot better
off if joe stayed on vacation anyway let
someone else more capable run the
country although kamala the giggling
vice president doesn't inspire
confidence nancy pelosi has her own
cognitive struggling going on so the
more things change the more they stay
the same take a look
it's clear
that the true problems of our nation
are much deeper
deeper than gasoline lines or energy
shortages deeper even
than inflation or recession
but after listening to the american
people
i have been reminded again
that all the legislation in the world
can't fix what's wrong with america
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else